frage was war das denn bitte für eine
wahl da in thüringen waren die alle
besoffen
jetzt reicht es in erfurt nur für eine
mehrheit aus linkspartei und cdu
ramelow mit mohring ich finds geil
er wird aber wohl leider nicht passieren
weil mohring kneift unglaublicher
wahlabend jedenfalls in thüringen die
afd verdoppelt ihr ergebnis in der
partei sprechen sie schon vom wunder von
bern tja da fällt mir ein liebe grüße an
die kollegen vom partner sender n tv
die waren rund um die wahl wirklich die
einzigen die einzigen die gucken sie mal
sorgfältig
ja
bei anderen sendern hat sich oft der
fehlerteufel eingeschlichen also
bisschen journalistische sorgfalt also
afd verdoppelt sich dafür verliert die
cdu in thüringen 11 prozent elf
historische klatsche und wieder kein
wort von angela merkel kein kommentar
kein mucks nichts absolute funkstille
ja es ist doch so gerade jetzt wo die
afg unsere liberale demokratie bedroht
wollen die leute noch mal was hören von
ihrer kanzlerin
ich meine das ernst was macht ihr dann
wirklich wo ist die frau
das ist das große rätsel das kann doch
nicht wahr sein hatte gewesen der in
indien ihr volk rechts nach orientierung
mir ist es egal
merkel muss echt aufpassen denn auch in
der cdu rumort es gewaltig friedrich
merz und andere blasen offen zur attacke
auf die kanzlerin und madame sitzt das
aus beben in der cdu
dicke luft statt diplomatie eine art
offene revolte es ist ein frontalangriff
kampf um die macht neu entfacht und neu
befeuert neu angeheizt da bläst einer
zum angriff mit voller wucht auf die
kanzlerin
jetzt mehrere stunden ihre partei
zerfleischt sich selbst und siko uhr zu
keiner weiß ja mehr soll der laden soll
die cdu nach rechts oder doch eher nach
links im grunde steht die union für
nichts mehr außer fürs immer weiter
regieren gleichzeitig kommen wissen sie
passend zu halloween merkels uhr alte
feinde aus der deckung
gruselig gruselig und vor allem fritze
märz hier denkt seine grosse stunde soll
endlich gekommen
ich sag mal bei dem herrscht jedenfalls
kein mangel an selbstbewusstsein
ich finde dieses land wird zur zeit
unter wert regiert und es gibt viele
menschen die mir zutrauen ist an der
einen oder anderen stelle vielleicht
besser machen zu können absolut also er
vor allem das interview haben sie
übrigens im westflügel seiner garage
gedreht da stehen die autos seiner frau
wer soll da noch kandidieren bei
parteitag gegen merkel soll er sich
trauen es gibt eine revolte gegen die
kanzlerin
wobei ich den frust in der partei sogar
in teilen verstehen kann
platz drei in thüringen für die cdu
wissen sie wann die cdu zuletzt mal
nicht auf platz eins oder zwei war
wir haben nachgeguckt 1951 in bremen
also nicht mal einen richtigen
bundesland
viele cdu leute wissen überhaupt nicht
mehr was das ist platz drei
ich erkläre euch mal dritter platz das
ist der hier schlimmer als trostpreis
beispiel wer erinnert sich noch an die
loser truppe die bei der wm 2006 dritter
wurde keiner warum auch versager oder
wer weiß noch wie die dritte frau von
gerhard schröder hieß
er selber nicht mehr in encino tief vor
doris und wer kennt wer kennt den
dritten von den wildecker herzbuben
niemand weil er immer von den beiden
anderen verdeckt wurde
endlich steht da ja kurz gesagt für
platz drei gibt es nur die urkunde die
cdu hat an der thüringen wahl
teilgenommen glückwunsch so aber wie
geht es jetzt weiter mit bernd hocke
diesem faschisten von dem alexander
gauland sagt er stehe in der mitte der
partei natürlich ist klar
260.000 260.000 thüringer haben letzten
sonntag afd gewählt und der band besteht
bei ikea schon möbel für den neuen
führerbunker bei den linken gewählt wer
die absolute mehrheit holen
das alte und morsche zerfällt vor
unseren augen
das ist gut so liebe freunde richtig
dass alte und morsche zerfällt und zwar
direkt links neben dir
[Applaus]
richtlinien ist meistens kein platz 23,4
prozent der thüringer entscheiden sich
ganz bewusst für einen mann den man laut
gerichtsurteil faschist nennen muss darf
entschuldigung so und wenn ich schon
höre sagen ja viele für dürfen die afg
wähler nicht weiter stigmatisieren sonst
verliert die demokratie die ganz wir
haben die doch längst verloren
jetzt müssen wir nur noch aufpassen dass
die hmi regieren wobei laut hackl leben
wir ja schon in einer diktatur
er macht sich nämlich sorgen dass das
die menschen spüren dass es in diesem
land etwas gibt ja das ist dass wir die
herrschaft der politischen korrektheit
nennen so eine art meinungs- druck ja
gewisse polit felder sind mit tabus
umstellten sprach verboten und
denkverboten umstellt versprach verboten
doch stellt früher waren die faschisten
nicht solche weicheier nur die afd
kämpft für die totale meinungsfreiheit
sagt sie immer alles sagen dürfen also
nicht alles natürlich ökoland merkel
darf laut gerichtsurteil als faschist
bezeichnet werden
sie wissen dass es unsinn ist sie wissen
dass bei uns die meinungsfreiheit in
manchen dingen für mich zu weit geht
ach so ja die bestimmen nämlich wo die
meinungsfreiheit hier endet übrigens
laut dem mehrfach erwähnten urteil darf
man hübsch ist nennen weil dieses und
die zitiere werturteil auf einer
überprüfbaren tatsachengrundlage beruht
zitat ende
ich behaupte höckers völkischer flügel
ist inzwischen die afd
oder gibts bei denen noch irgendwas
anderes das klären wir jetzt
aktenzeichen xy ungelöst mit christian
ehring
[Musik]
neben zuschauer heute fanden wir nach
der sogenannten gemäßigten afd
was ist das wo ist die un haben sie in
letzter zeit mal einen gemäßigten af
deser gesehen sind sie so selten doch ja
ja ja ja dann sind sie haben wir bislang
nur eingestellt ich das foto von einem
gemäßigten nahe wähler hier da ist und
eben thüringer wald tatsächlich einer in
eine fotofalle gelaufen leider ganz
schlechte qualität also man sieht das
ist ein thüringer ist klar aber sonst
gehabt männchen weibchen keine ahnung in
jedem fall eine bedrohte art denn die
partei wird gerade komplett vom
sogenannten flügel übernommen
die afg 2009 10 ist im grunde noch 1
was hat sie im mittelteil gesagt naja ok
im sommer gab es mal einen kleinen
gemäßigten zwergenaufstand da haben sich
100 afd anhänger in einem brief über den
köpfen personenkult beschwert wobei ich
war kritisch nachfragen möchte wo ist
denn da bitte ein personenkult
ihr offizieller imagefilm nicht von uns
bearbeitet
[Musik]
ja immer mit beiden händen ganz wichtig
mit einer sieht komisch aus aber da ist
für mich kein personenkult erkennbar
oder ist es einfach ein geiler typ ein
volk ein bernd einer ecke genau ich habe
gelesen hatte will tatsächlich eine art
system sturz system umsturz wer schreibt
mit seinem buch zitat ein paar
korrekturen und reförmchen werden nicht
ausreichen wenn einmal die wende zeit
gekommen ist dann machen wir deutschen
keine halben sachen
trotzdem sieht den in der mitte der
partei wo sind ihnen jörg morgen die
einmal doch angeblich mal gemäßigt j
morgen ihren worden ich sag mal so
der traut sich was würde einige position
von herrn hüppe wenn ich sie in das
rechts links rechts continum einordnen
müsste nicht als mittig klassifizieren
er würde einige höhere positionen im
rechts links kontinuum nicht als mittig
klassifizieren
das ist ja fast schon antifaschismus
wollten muss wirklich aufpassen dieser
verräter wird bestimmt bald aus
sämtlichen afd fotos retuschiert ja
alice light und schmeißt diese warum
zuhörer wem hustenanfällen aus dem sack
gibt es überhaupt noch einen einen
prominenten gemäßigten fdp
beim nächsten parteitag über dem
türkischen laden komplett und der findet
wohl start in braunschweig kann man sich
nicht aus kurz gesagt wir stellen die
fahndung ein bitte rufen sie nicht mehr
an es gibt keine gemäßigte afd genauso
wenig wie einen guten song von dieter
bohlen oder leckeres veganes essen
existiert nicht
aber nächste woche bitten wir wieder um
ihre mithilfe da suchen wir einen warte
mal erfolgreichen spd politiker 8
[Applaus]